Donald Trump Jr in another one of these
manic rants has lashed out at Ron
DeSantis the Civil War is on 100 percent
controlled opposition whatever you want
to say about Trump versus DeSantis and I
will be the first to tell you Trump is
the guy who has the position of power
here Trump is the guy with the advantage
Trump is the guy who if nothing changes
is going to win that Republican
nomination they wouldn't all be going
after DeSantis if they didn't believe
DeSantis represents at least some threat
to Donald Trump every day Trump is
posting about Ron DeSantis on Truth
social and now you've got the henchmen
joining the attacks Don Jr uh Mike
pillow was recently attacking Ron
DeSantis Steve Bannon was attacking Ron
DeSantis so we're going to follow this
very closely but Don Jr manically and
maniacally going after Des Sanctus